statistic maybe uh vincent's chance to
actually beat an informed janna
pomnyocci is to go to the end game wow
this is going to be interesting and look
at them they are ready john pognati in
the same sweater that he's been wearing
the entire tournament it must be his
lucky sweater and let's see if i can
bring him some luck today what you
expect in this first game david young
with the white pieces i'm expecting jan
to try and assert his control assert his
dominance against his young rival in the
first game jan does start with white
that is traditionally a bit of an
advantage jan extremely dangerous with
the white pieces i'm very well prepared
due to the world championship match and
all the work he did for that so i'm
expecting jan to unleash something maybe
quite direct as well against vincent who
prefers the longer games who prefers the
end games as we saw in the stats and
okay a sicilian defense a bit of a
surprise already because vincent kaima
known for the karo khan known for
ivanka's favorite opening instead
playing the sicilian
one of yan's own openings against him
and will we see an open sicilian we do
this means it's going to be a
full-blooded fight hey
the night or sicilian kaya it's your
favorite opening
and uh okay this is still main line
theory we saw a trade of pawns in the
center now white and black have both
both castled their kings so a bit of a
strategic
approach to the opening to the open
sicilian but uh still very well known
stuff so far
all right well uh i did mention jan he's
wearing that same sweater and i think
we've seen that from him before is he
one of those superstitious players
uh possibly or maybe maybe he's got like
four or five of those sweaters
i just hope he watches it occasionally
or it's just because he loves you guys
so much yeah it's definitely a good
design so yeah yeah and actually i
noticed this is one thing that russian
players tend to do they're very
superstitious i first played jan when we
were eight nine years old and he was
doing the same back then he would only
change his outfit if he'd lost a game
wow and uh he's doing so well in the
tournament so far in the air things
masters that maybe he just doesn't want
to change things up change his routine
yet
and uh meanwhile just a very tense
position this last bishop moved by white
solidifying the pawn center
if you look at the knights on that left
side that's where white's strength lies
and now black are trying to challenge
one of the white knights maybe trying to
relocate that black knight back towards
the center of the board
and uh vincent he's a very strategic
player we mentioned peter lecko is the
common denominator between these two
players yeah simon said it he's the
coach of both of them
and maybe that's why vincent very early
on playing an opening he's not maybe
as familiar with compared to his
opponent compared to yan but
he just wants to surprise him and uh
okay it has become quite strategic if
the opening was really really wild then
i think that would definitely favor jan
and his style but right now after a
night trade white's queen has just
stepped up a bit of a threat in the
position actually but uh
yeah it's still balanced if black is
accurate here both of them stacking up
some time in the opening here we should
mention that
they obviously have the same time
control as in the preliminaries here
it's rapid chess and each of the
quarterfinal matches they finish their
game and then they will have 15 minutes
before their next game starts so
it's going to be a chaotic day it's
going to be games going on all the time
we're going to try to make it to as many
games and as many of the quarterfinal
matches as we possibly can but we are
starting out with this one because yeah
it is such an interesting battle between
the turn uh the preliminary winner the
young vincent kymer and treasurer
lekko's
students do you think he is helping them
in this tournament
i think peter lecker is pretty busy with
commentary yeah right i think he is and
i was just gonna say um normally when
you work with someone
um and that that someone is playing
another one of your students you kind of
back away that's kind of the main thing
that you do in chess you kind of say
back that's the point yeah yeah yeah and
for sure there will be all sorts of um
clauses in the contract that he has in
the promise that he can't share that
information not even with his most uh
trusted student
how do you guys normally do simon ivanka
when you're playing someone you know
very well or a friend maybe or someone
you've worked with in the past i i used
to find it very hard playing someone
especially who is a friend um i have
many times where i i just didn't want to
play them um because obviously you share
a point with them after the game
you enjoy you know their company but
when you're playing and i think it's
harder when you can see them in the
flesh actually rather than over the
internet but um when you're in that
situation you just got to turn
everything off you've got to turn those
emotions off and just try to kill them
basically and
yeah so it's like a switch you just got
to get in the zone and switch things off
all these top players can do that
they're very experienced at uh getting
into the zone
yep
fully agreed uh i've often played
friends expecting them to go easy on me
but they never do
chess is brutal in that way and uh if we
just catch up with the position just to
show what's been happening vincent
actually just pushing upon uh pawn over
here and hospital say is white going to
do the same this is cool
in the studio exactly exactly we saw
this yesterday actually happen in that
uh big encounter between kostenik and
eric hansen eric forgot to give the
black king some breathing space and he
got checkmated on the background so now
both sides have air for their king uh
they're looking after the air quality of
those kings
and meanwhile the other dynamic factors
in the position are mostly to do with
this black pawn it's a backward pawn
it's going to struggle to advance
forward because white has such good
control over this square it's an outpost
white's knight might want to use it
later but also the pawn guards this
square the bishop guards the square
directly the queen guards this square
and this long term is a target however
as compensation black does have a semi
open line for the black queen for the
black rook and that might give him
counter play later in the game these
positions are so hard to master because
black does have an extra central pawn
actually
it's level pawns in general but black
has two in this on the central files uh
compared to white's one and that means
long term he's doing well but short term
he does have the issue of this pawn also
white has a clamp
on some very important squares white
bishop can come and attack the black
queen it's going to be hard for black to
get active and maybe napoleon actually
just wants to control things and wait
for kamer to get frustrated or to try
and break out at a moment that black
won't be ready how about that super far
advanced white pawn on the edge there is
that going to be a strength or a
weakness
it could be both uh alice the aporn or
harry the a pawn according to simon at
the moment it's supported by a white
rook but you could imagine a situation
where the rooks come off the queens come
off and then later this pawn might be a
bit lonely out on its own at the moment
though it's doing a great job of
stopping black's pawn from marching
forward because then we would see on
passon uh for example if black moves two
uh two squares forward white could
capture this pawn as if it just moved
once
a bit of a funny rule that one i've
always thought but uh it is kind of
funny yeah i guess why is it a rule in
chess
difficult what is the point of it it's a
good one for the audience at home i
think you know uh or mr google our
friend
google the origins
isn't it to do with the fact that the
pawns used to only move one square at a
time ah and then they change the rules
so on the first move you can move it two
squares at a time so that it's still
possible why this happened again it's a
mystery to me and uh if anyone will care
to explain to us you can tweet us using
the
chess champs or if you also want to get
involved in the action and the fun and
send us your selfies your questions
then also use the hashtag and we will
feature them on the show definitely yeah
that's the thing about chess players we
know the rules but sometimes we forget
we forget why we know them or why the
rules exist or we struggle to explain
them some famous cases actually went
there in uh high level um encounters
where top players have forgotten the
rules you had one case where courchnoy
uh was playing a long time ago he was
one of the strongest players never to
become a world champion and he had to
ask the arbiter if he could i think this
is how it goes if he could castle in a
certain position uh because he was
moving his rook through the attack of uh
bishop so uh you would have thought
they'd know how to parcel that level but
um i think that's how the story goes but
uh yeah very very strange how did the
armature react to that then um i think i
i guess he was a bit surprised and you
know i said you're asking me how to
castle you're you're playing for the
world championship soon
you should probably know this rule
already you know so like yeah
yeah yeah actually i've i've found that
arbiter's no fewer rules than some of
the players that obviously really i
don't want to complain better are we
going back to your afterwards again
we love the arbiters out there if you're
an arbiter you're doing a fantastic
yeah
this is where chess and football is very
alike
always complain about the the referees
or the arbiters yeah it's never the
player's fault it's always someone
else's fault
meanwhile we just heard a couple of
moves there not too much changing the
status quo will maintain for the next
few moves white just shuffling a rook
across black did the same on the last go
and uh yeah despite the computer
evaluation saying 0.0 i've always
slightly preferred these positions for
white just because as black there's no
pawn breaks no matter what pawn you push
it will get captured and if you can't
play with pawns that means you're you
have to resort to playing with pieces
and it's not clear where your pieces
want to go there's always downsides to
any piece move as well
maybe a very clever choice from uh yan
because uh obviously this is uh quite
this is maybe a position vincent doesn't
have a lot of experience in so um he
might not know what maneuvers he should
be doing as much as jan who's obviously
the older player knows these positions
maybe more and you can see he's frowning
there a little bit of that last move
maybe he's finding that that night move
or vincent's a little bit peculiar is
that is that a strange move do you think
david trying to re-route the knight i i
expect around to uh the queen side
somewhere can he even go to b8 is that
is that where he's going yeah possibly
and i think the reason jan was frowning
just to explain um you mentioned simon
this knight has stepped back it can
maybe re-route itself it takes a long
time though um re-routes itself to a
square where it's actually attacking
this white pawn that we highlighted
earlier but that takes three moves and
the reason jan did frown is because now
he's pounced he's jumped in to the
center with his knight this square no
longer controlled by black's knight we
mentioned this is an outpost in front of
black's backward pawn and now if the
knight is captured
white's plan is to take back with his
queen and it looks like white is hanging
a pawn to the black queen but if the
black queen jumps in and captures the
spawn now white is also able to do the
same and both queens are active but if
you look at the pieces these two bishops
long term are going to be far superior
to black's minor pieces especially this
black bishop look at it it's terrible
it's blocked in just doing a defensive
job and not just that but this pawn is
weak and if this pawn drops then white's
a pawn that we mentioned is going to
start running so that trade is only
going to be favorable for white in the
current position and if he doesn't take
this then vincent could maybe think
about capturing this pawn first but then
white would have options for example
including taking this bishop with check
and then okay he actually takes and then
goes back with his knight but this pawn
would have dropped in this variation
attacking the black rook so let's catch
up with the game instead of this
he took this knight and now went back to
where he came from with his own knight
but still same problem the white queen
retreats and now if queen takes pawn the
white queen takes and white has an
advantage i think strategically now
white is doing very well yeah i was
gonna say um one thing that really
appeal uh jumps out to me is the fact
that uh he traded his light squad i'm
sorry vincent traded his light squared
bishop which was the one of the most
powerful minor pieces for the night
and he's left himself with a really
really bad bishop
this bishop is kind of like it's a
nightmare it's never ever going to get
out
yeah totally and and it's just doing one
roll defending that backward central
pawn i i think this shows that he's just
lacking a bit of experience and yan
picked a very clever maneuvering game
where okay maybe vincent knows the first
sort of 15 moves to the position but he
may as he hasn't played this opening uh
often he doesn't know those middle game
plans and knowing those middle game
plans is so important and this is what a
lot of people at home probably uh forget
to do they they
learn the opening but then they get into
the middle game it's like what do i do
here you know what moves do i play in
this position and in some ways i feel
that vincent's falling for this trick
and he's uh done a bad exchange there
yeah and one thing i was just going to
add to that isn't the night off napoli
actually has bread and butter you know
his defense yeah he's he's experiencing
his whole career
and uh you mentioned the word trick as
well uh there's a cur there is a trick
in the current position black can
actually win a pawn grab a pawn with the
black knight but this would be uh
sealing its own fate this walks into a
deadly pin and at the very minimum white
could lift the rook up the board double
attack this knight now with the rook and
with the bishop and black actually can't
move it because the queen would drop off
and uh there's no way of
really defending it either remember that
this pawn can't move forward because
this pawn is also pinned by the white
queen and this would be disaster time
for black so yeah you guys are right um
it's a really risky strategy playing
your opponent's favorite opening against
them
and jan again going back to when he was
eight nine years old he was already
playing this opening from the black side
so for sure he knows what white's plans
are as well is pinning a very beginner
thing or do we see a lot of times top
players as well falling to these pins
i think all levels affects us i've lost
so many games to pins in my career and i
remember even a few recent games against
grandmasters i've managed to use pins
maybe isn't the deciding factor in the
game because
when you kind of get stronger you
realize how to break pins but it it is a
recurring theme for sure it's one of the
most important ones to know pins double
attacks those types of things
yeah you learn them when you're starting
the game but they are still always
relevant
yeah i think a good bit of advice for
anyone out there there's loads of things
especially you can go to chesapeal where
they have these courses uh just teaching
you the the basic uh things about pins
and forks and you build that into your
game and you find more complex uh ideas
based on based on those strategies it's
a very good way to improve but
again looking at the position here i
mean this to me looks i i think the word
disgusting is is okay i mean
white's got so many easy plans here he
can bring the rook around on the queen
side um as ivanka uh pointed out losing
that light square bishop just seems
horrible doesn't it i mean
you're losing your most precious piece
and
it's torture for black black can't
really do anything the ideas that i'm
really attracted to if i were playing
with white pieces is actually
to lift my rook up on the a line move it
all the way to the fourth full square
and then try to do some
little action there
you know line up with the queen have
some fun
yeah swing it all the way around to that
hole
i love these swingers i love the
swingers i think they were called i
think it was jennifer shahad who said
the rover
from yeah okay
the the rover rook the rook over so but
it's a very nice way to get a rook into
the game and uh why not um but what
would you do here is black i'm just
trying to think of struggling as well
you haven't got any counter play and you
need you need to have some counter play
and i just can't see where it's going to
come from and he's down 10 minutes
he's swinging it yeah he's swinging it
in
getting active yes swinging it swinging
it
yeah that 10 minute advantage is gonna i
think decide this game because vincent
it's not just that he's ten minutes down
on the clock black's last move doesn't
really improve his position
that black rook in the center of the
board on the d file it's just blocked in
black can never push that backward pawn
forward white has maximum control on
this position and uh this rook maneuver
that you guys have been discussing i
think it it's going to overwhelm black's
defenses the white rook can just step
across one square attack a pawn jump
into the position harass the black queen
and it's going to be already back to the
wartime for vincent yeah i mean
i was thinking well maybe at least the
knight can maneuver itself and uh yep
it's been played by vincent
but uh
no it's certainly not the queen the
black queen is almost on the verge of
getting trapped yeah and black's knight
note how it doesn't have any outposts no
matter where it jumps later on there is
the potential for white to kick it away
with a pawn so
i'm expecting here napoli actually to
just move his rook across one square
you could also make an argument for
moving the white bishop to create a pin
uh the white light squared bishop do you
think black is trying to uh meet the
rook coming over one square by pushing
the center
i actually thought maybe jan could go
bishop h5 there
first to force the rook away but this
this also makes a lot of sense he's just
trying to tie down uh black's pieces
again using that pin he's using that
strategy he's trying to pin down that
knight so it can't move and uh black's
in danger of uh running out of moves uh
white's got control of so many squares
uh as well this is this is just looking
pretty horrendous uh the one of the
things i love about jan is his
expressions um
you know when he when his opponent plays
a bad move
it's like he will let everyone know you
know it's like
what is this guy doing he's he's doing
something crazy
very similar to kasparov actually
kasparov was the same
over the board he'd very very uh
expressive um
over his opponent's moves and his own
moves but what can black do here i don't
know completely stuck black would love
to jump forward with this knight
attacking the white queen attacking the
rook this is a fork but white just
eliminates this knight and no matter
what happens next this rook does drop
off note how it's important as well
white's queen defends this rook so black
can only go for a trade but black's lost
some material in the meantime and this
is just a fatal pin this is already or
so hard for black to get out of
well it's looking really really good for
white in this in the first set of
quarterfinal games here magnus carlsen
the bar is over to his side in the first
game against liam lehr and the bar is
also way over to andreas penko's side in
his first game against underdog eric
hansen but between ding and artem i
think the bar is roughly in the middle
and the bar on this one is saying uh ish
like one advantage for janupomniacchi
but it's hounds like on you guys that it
should be even more yeah it's also the
type of position where
it's quite a long term plus one plus two
and uh it could well shoot up if vincent
isn't careful
and uh actually i thought this last move
was impossible but maybe uh black can
hold things together with some tip uh
tricks with some tactics
at first i thought white's dark squared
bishop could jump into the position and
um cause some trouble but
it's really hanging by a thread already
for black and you notice the evaluation
part went slightly up there in white's
favor even more
and uh could even be some trouble with
the black queen here maybe you take that
night off um
possibly okay he's just moved the rook
over which also makes sense right yeah
you wanted to swing it across that rook
and it is starting to move across the
board it's starting to do it's
maneuvering um white rooks are looking
really nice yeah look at black syrups in
comparison both completely blocked
black's dark squared bishop ugly ugly
piece
black's knight is the only piece that
can really fight against
white's control and domination of all
the squares but no matter where the
black knight jumps to
at the very minimum as simon mentioned
it can just get traded off yeah and uh
okay he does jump to attack the white
queen i don't think we'll see white take
that knight yet uh white's queen can
just move to safety
there we go and
still the tension
is all in white's favor and like you
said david that knight can just get uh
driven back
it's not safe
nothing is safe for for black
okay so at least he's trying to trade
off his bad bishop for white's strong
dark squared bishop if those bishops
leave the board maybe maybe vincent's
got some chance to save the game i was
going to ask because this is a 17 year
old then you always say that young
players they're very optimistic about
their positions they look at them and
maybe you know see okay at least this
piece is a good piece so if vincent is
doing that what what can he be
optimistic about here uh
not too much but uh yeah at least he's
trying to get rid of one of his bad
pieces trade off one of his opponent's
strong pieces i actually played vincent
a few months ago in the final round of
the grand swiss and um it was such an
important game the winner would qualify
for the grand prix and um i mean there
was a lot of money on the line as well
and for most of the game i was in charge
i had maybe one winning move but then
after the game he was like yeah yeah i
was fine i was had it all under control
and
optimism you said it kaya so this is the
type of position where black is the one
suffering he's not lost yet it's still
level material
i think it's got a lot better for black
hasn't it here it seems to be just over
the course the last moves i mean i'm not
saying it's great
but you've got now what we call opposite
kind of bishops and that gives the the
drawing chances now are much higher even
if you lose a pawn you get to an ending
they can never attack each other so
there's much more much more defensive
possibilities um in the position and i
feel yan maybe should have captured that
knight
and kept you know kept
that dark square bishop on the board
even
some chances here to hold possibly um i
for reckon
some chances but it has to be done in a
really clever way because uh those two
pawns that black has on the left there
are light squares and one drops the
other one will drop and then this this
runner that white has is going to be a
problem so it has to be done in a like
maybe with the rooks on the board and
maybe kind of curling up into a little
ball
yeah it's getting tough it's going to be
hard to make trades actually here i mean
for example if white just keeps the
queens on you could maybe make an
argument for taking the queens off but
if at the very minimum you keep the
queens on the board what is black
actually doing white's rook is going to
step forward kicking the black queen
away
i mean if black just makes a move for
example okay he does actually do this
the reason i choose this square is to
defend this pawn and now if black just
makes a move for example then white's
rook will step up black's queen retreats
white's other rook steps up and look at
the black queen already struggling for
squares i think black's going to lose a
pawn here
so
already
yes it's opposite color bishops but you
still need to work very hard uh to save
this game black's rook is still passive
this is still a backward pawn and as
your mankind mentions these guys weak as
well long term on the light squares and
meanwhile black's bishop not too many
targets for it yeah okay
i say that and then it targets a pawn
but uh that is easily defended by
white's rook
yeah so but i mean
still lots of things to
to think about um we do have an answer
from twitter about our ampersand
question
so casper agrees with us ampersand was
invented just to confuse your opponent
that's my thought
i agree uh kev double07 says
ampersand rule dates to the 15th century
when the pawn rule changed to allow the
pawn to move two squares to its first
move and so prevents the two square
advance without the risk of capture so
yeah okay our audience always
enlightening us yeah thank you thank you
yeah i think it's a rule that confuses
most beginners uh on pass on uh you know
if you're playing and you're just
starting chess and you're playing your
dad and they do one pass on and you're
like come on you're cheating you can't
do this move um but yeah it makes some
sense to as the rules change things
slightly changed to make it better um i
just look at his position as well i was
looking at at the bishops and
ideally another uh thing that white
could do is just bring his bishop right
around into the center um you know if i
if i can maybe put it on the square
david on in the middle of the board
it would just control the king side the
queen side
and the problem black has black can't
put his bishop really anywhere that good
um okay it's it's on the side of the
board
not really doing a great deal i know
white's just moved the king but okay
it's not a problem at all
so white can improve his pieces but
black can't improve his pieces um even
though that's always a good move isn't
it h5 it was a fine move how are you
marching up the board but then again it
does force white to play a move that
maybe he wants to play anyway the one
you highlighted bringing the bishop back
and about to line it up with the white
queen on this great diagonal that's
where the black king steps out of the
firing line we so know we so need a name
for that bishop
that david put the put in the middle of
the board
shooting at every single square
yeah yeah
turbo bishop
star wars bishop
i envisioned it with the star wars
swords maybe an octo bishop you've
coined the octonaut
i believe there was a book very old book
written about this champion fishing
right
von winkle
was it going back to the 12th century he
pictured this bishop in the middle of
the board and he called it the the
octopy
um maybe we can get someone to google
and bring it up to the otp bishop we've
fallen for your lies too many times
simon okay
so
i think but again you know if you're out
there and you've got more stats than
that then please do correct me i can't
believe that we all fell for that all of
us
if anchor nearly caught me out there i
feel like i saw you had a bit of doubt
in your yeah when you said winkle but uh
suddenly i'm sorry i got bit distracted
by the game because suddenly things are
heating up
a pawn break in the middle of the board
so it's a porn sacrifice yeah yeah this
is a
strategic sacrifice as well it's not
necessarily uh planning to win the pawn
back any time soon white can actually
take this pawn in two different ways
with the white rook or with his own pawn
but he's just trying to break out
use the black rooks use the black bishop
in active ways just while white isn't
fully organized if you look at white's
bishop it was about to reach a great
diagonal and that's why timing was
everything vincent didn't want to see
that happen and he breaks out and
instructive stuff from the 17 year old
not prioritizing material instead
prioritizing activity and also white's
king a bit strangely placed so maybe
just using this specific moment and
maybe we can explain the reasoning
behind the porn sacrifice the specific
ideas
if for example white just takes back
with his pawn then black has options one
idea would be to push this pawn forward
at the right moment
uh you could even just blockade white's
extra pawn for now you could for example
move forward with your rook get rid of
this annoying piece in your camp and
after a trade suddenly the quality of
the bishops white's bishop is not so
good and black's bishop has the
potential to become very strong if
things open up and okay rooks have left
the board so not going for this pawn
capture instead taking with his rook and
after rook takes rook what do we think
we'll see here from jan
is he going to take with the queen is he
going to take with the pawn taking with
the pawn looks sensible but then again
white's queen is offside and black's
queen is very well placed so i would be
tempted to at least calculate going for
the queen trade first um if we could
just go back queen takes rook maybe
would encourage a queen trade but then
again opposite color bishops
and a position like this if black
attacks the white rook the white rook
will be forced back to a bad square and
suddenly black can start pushing forward
with his pawns white's bishop white's
rook are much worse place than they
previously were i mean look at that rook
that's just moved as well david i mean
like it's completely you stuck out the
game day
at the moment and this is this is this
is a great move from vincent d5 that
shows real majority to play this move
and again this is just looking at the
games of much lower rate of players one
of the things that i've noted that lower
rated players do as a common mistake is
uh try to defend too passively so they
get a position and they don't want to
sack a pawn for activity if you look at
the games the higher rate of players
they're very willing to play an idea
like this okay go upon down but free up
their pieces so i i think active defense
is always the best defense if you can do
it which vincent is is doing here yeah
and now a big big moment for
janupomnishi does he retreat his rook
but then as we mentioned this rook
actually has no escape squares it might
be stuck for a long long time uh or does
jan try and play the safer move uh just
pushing his pawn forward
counter-attacking against the black rook
but then again black could just take
this rook and recapture and we would see
an opposite color bishop end game
probably this is just going to end in a
draw so jan just calculating the risk
right now does he push this pawn forward
attacking the black rook or does he try
and keep his winning chances but risk
his rook being caught out of the game
and black has a simple plan as well
pushing these guys forward in queens off
i guess i mean we are in the end game
and we did see the inches that's that is
where
young vincent karmer is at his very best
yeah and look at vincent he's much more
happy uh much more focused as well than
he was earlier it cost him a lot of time
to get to this position but it was worth
that time investment he found that
critical pawn break and
yan meanwhile
head in hands much
less happy i think i'm very similar it's
very in body language to yan when i play
uh it's really interesting if you go to
a chess tournament over the board and
just look at everyone's different body
language because
whenever something goes wrong for me i
just hide in my hands you know i try to
i try to just get out of the
view
of everyone around me and uh it's it
seems to be that yan's realized he's
he's kind of uh you know thrown it away
yeah in a lot of respects there he's
he's
advantage he had and he's allowed his
young opponent to to play some great
ideas and get in the game yeah allowing
that pawn break was the kind of
crucial um idea
um
what do you reckon do you reckon he's
going to push the pawn play it safe kind
of admit that maybe
maybe you know vincent has been
doing a good job defending or is he
going to keep the nice
he keeps the tensions he keeps tension
keeps the poor i was a little bit
worried about him doing this actually
because it does look
you know to all intents and purpose
really good but you know that in order
to get out that white the pawn sitting
on c3 is going to have to
push one square forward and suddenly
black's bishop is incredibly powerful on
this dark's class it's quite risky i
mean in some ways black could uh
black could turn this around if you push
too much you end up losing um and that
would be
extremely hard to deal with with the
white pieces so i sometimes
again you've just got to say right i've
messed this up take a draw and move on
to the next game um and he's played that
move uh keeping the extra pawns but
black's bishop which was his worst piece
has just become fantastic now and the
black king moving into the center can
even push the central pawn so okay this
is an interesting move jan yeah and try
to open things up there
yep and i think an important move
white's rook needs to find some scope
some activity and i was also about to
say the evaluation bar around level now
but earlier it was the type of position
which was a long-term advantage for
white now
it could go either way if white's able
to use his extra pawn then the
evaluation bar will shoot up in white's
favor but if black continues the
momentum and look at this pushing harry
forward blocking things up black keeping
uh the white rook from using any squares
on this right side of the board if
black's able to push the central pawns
forward if black's king is able to get
even closer to the center i think we'll
see a black advantage
it is super dangerous so hard to play
for white there's no plan black's plan
is easy white has no plan every single
piece is dominated by the black pieces i
mean uh this is not really a worthwhile
extra pawn at all i don't think and we
can see jan now taking on f5 but uh it's
also hard for white to find a plan here
he needs to get his pieces in the game
how'd you get your pieces into the game
here black's got the easier strategy
just pushing in the center centralizing
the king and coming forwards would you
rather be white or black here david if
you would take that yeah you take black
times out of 100. what a change yeah
what a change around didn't you franco
you'd
have 1 000 you know because the plan is
so simple for black you know just
david's highlighting
mobilize the king the end and uh what's
white going to do some
hoppety hop with the verb come in i mean
i say hopity hop
because he would love to make some
illegal moves
you would love to bring this rook round
somehow and put it on an open file but
the problem is everywhere you go for
example this square is controlled by the
black bishop and that's why if we go
back to the current position just
showing the idea that of black's plan
pushing forward white has stepped his
rook across uh across the board so
now i guess he wants to meet this pawn
push maybe with a counter-attack by
pushing his own pawn forward hitting the
blackrook and this would free up white's
pieces now a porn trade is not uh rook
trade sorry it's not possible because
white would actually go and make a new
queen and therefore black's rook would
have to move out the way and at least
now finally the white rook is active
again so a sneaky sneaky move there from
napolishi he wants to push this pawn
forward on the next go it is his extra
pawn after all and it is a past pawn so
i expect vincent to take a time out to
stop that plan
or maybe even just plant his bishop in
the center of the board at some point
just to block this white rook wow well
the bar has shifted side but the clocks
are you guys it's down to one minute and
48 seconds for vincent keimer
janoponyacio he has a big time advantage
at least
yeah and okay he plays the move that i
thought maybe he wouldn't go for vincent
i i assume now white is going to push
that central pawn forward before it's
too late before the tide completely
turns in black's favor
and the more i look at it the more i
think black can just bail out with a
draw there but
so if you could have looked for more so
if you do push
the d pawn forwards and you go move the
rook over maybe we can just show this
line i'm just wondering if white can
move the rook to where the white pawn is
is that is that a possible tricky line
at least that black has to be but okay
you can take with a rook yeah yeah this
is what i think vincent has planned he's
going to play rook takes pawn and
counter attack because now black's
bishop will drop off but then suddenly
the white bishop will drop off as well
and uh the same game is at least fine
for black white has more weaknesses if
anything for example this pawn lonely
and isolated so i'm expecting to see
this actually happen on the board pawn
pushing forward the rook sliding across
and then most likely now just a rook
trade and
black is better here because the king is
coming into the center and maybe even
this pawn dropping off but white should
be able to hold this one i think
yeah it's ugly though
right yeah i'm talking about like you
know being almost easily won foreign and
that that was very difficult for vincent
to hold it and then suddenly
vincent's turned it around
i think he's played fantastically to to
get back into this but also jan has uh
let it slip a little bit yeah in his in
his court
so it all turned on that one move right
that pawn break yeah and i found that is
the most effective move in chess
putting a pawn or putting a piece on a
square that your opponent thinks they
have covered several times because it
will just ruin their coordination if all
of your opponent's pieces are looking at
the same square they can't all occupy
the square
and okay we do see this pawn push
another move i just realized is possible
for white after the black rook side
steps is to bring the white bishop out
and attack that rook
and there most likely as well we'll see
some trades and
the game most likely should end in a
draw but white is the defender here for
sure yeah and uh okay nepo there just
smiling slightly he knows he's up
against it is he going to move his rook
forward out of the attack or is he going
to continue the counter threats against
the black rook with the white bishop now
going to the edge of the board and
hitting that black rook
um
yeah they both look fine to me actually
but
i would probably bring my bishop out now
yeah
putting the bishop out is a
nice right okay so he brings this rook
up and we will say rook takes pawn as we
showed on the board
okay opposite color bishops we know what
that means normally but is this an
exception
that is the question yeah i i think
there should be a draw i mean like i
can't see how either side would would
win this um black just that's quite a
safety first move right stopping white's
uh bishop moving into the position
quite classy isn't it yeah
yeah dominating the bishop you know i
thought oh the white bishop at least is
going to get active no it says vincent
well vincent's going to be a pawn up now
yeah uh i'm you know we couldn't expect
that from a long time ago obviously it's
a it's a draw um but he's a porno
yeah and uh these opposite color bishops
are just going to balance each other out
white is going to blockade on the light
squares black will not be able to break
through on that color complex so
are they allowed to offer draws um i
think they are
at this point in the game
not before move 30 but yeah
normally we very rarely see draw offers
actually yeah we normally see the
players find a way to repeat the moves
or
often the players are too proud to click
that offer draw button they just want to
keep going and make their opponent
be the ones to submit and offer the draw
and jan wouldn't offer now right with
the white pieces and he is a pr pride
proud uh player as well yeah it's also
chess etiquette it's like good manners
so if you're a pawn down here with white
you know your opponent is the only one
trying to win so you let your opponent
do what they want but then they are the
ones offering a draw so it's always the
side who's better in an end game who
should be the one to offer the draw and
seize the winning chances uh winning
attempts one of the most annoying things
i think that can happen when you're
playing is someone keep offering you
draws which is which is kind of legal
but you can have this in a game and yeah
i had this against some junior uh he's
probably 14 years old but he offered me
one draw and it's like
no
you're polite normally you say no i'd
rather play on and then like a move
later draw and you're like then you
don't answer and then a move later draw
and you give it a bit more of an evil
look and the fourth time you're like
right
arbiter
wake up over there and come over here
put that cup of tea down
and uh but it's really annoying if
someone keeps offering you drinks yeah
and it's going to take time as well
right
it's very frustrating yeah really
frustrating so yeah that being said i
did once play a simultaneous exhibition
where
you play several people at the same time
you walk around in a circle playing on
every board and i think i was playing a
five-year-old and
i was i was a few moves away from
checkmate and then the draw offer came
and the hand came just looking at me
with the wide eyes please draw
i said no the first three or four times
but he kept saying draw whenever i came
around so i said okay
did he put the water works on a little
bit yeah yeah
okay but then as soon as i shook his
hand with the drawer he was jumping off
bouncing boasting to his friends
was i also involved in the simultaneous
because i have a suspicion that there
was there was also another situation
okay well
that was just a case of
moving the bishops yeah unfortunately
wow jan is actually going to demonstrate
something really nice here but
unfortunately for black no matter what
he does even if he wins the white bishop
if it comes at the cost of those two
black pawns on the left side it's a dead
draw white can just keep his king in the
right hand corner on the light square
and there's no breakthrough i hope we
see that because
yeah you could be four points up with
nothing else on the board and it's still
a draw and i remember a tournament i
played okay they haven't gone down to it
which is a little bit